voyez donc appartenir à une aristocratie
des lecteurs oui bien sûr enfin bien sûr
je sais pas si j'y appartiens je suis
persuadé qu'il faut une aristocratie de
l'hectare que pensez-vous du Livre de
Poche beaucoup de mal pourquoi parce que
ça fait lire un tableau de gens qui
n'avaient pas besoin de lire finalement
qui n'avait jamais ressenti le besoin de
lire on les a amenés là on leur disait
nous deux ou la vie en fleur et la seule
couille se sont retrouvés avec Sartre
dans les mains
ce qui leur a donné une espèce de
prévention intellectuelle qui n'avait
pas c'est à dire que les gens avant les
gens étaient humbles devant finalement
la littérature alors que maintenant se
permettre de la prendre de haut
le droit de mépris maintenant parce
qu'il n'avait pas avant